I wanted to start off with you Bob and
ask you how did as producer how did you
first hear about the project had to get
attached to it well what what what
attracted to you to you well a couple
things attracted to me I was a big an
early supporter of President Obama and
also the film being shot in Chicago was
a big thing for me and I just thought
Richard wrote an amazing script and it
was interesting because teeka first
brought me the script maybe a year and a
half before they started shooting and I
just saw teeka's passion and how much he
was talking about it when she was on
board and then I loved it but I said I
don't know how to find the money for
this I wish I could do it I just being
very forward and honest and then I was
fortunate enough where like a year later
it came back and I sat down with rich
and Rich's vision of what he wrote was
so on point like you could tell he shot
the film five six times in his head and
he was so prepared and so disciplined
and ready to make it that it was like
the combination of everything just made
a lot of sense at the time because it's
really a unique film and that it's not
like a biopic and it's not really um you
know about just them but say a romance
film and I was wondering how how did you
approach other people that were becoming
a project a project in terms of talking
about the story how did you frame it
well it was interesting because it's you
know we kind of mala it after like a
Linkletter film which he's done so well
in the past was before sunrise and after
sunset and it was just an intricate
story and I think people you know
everybody up here could jump in but it
was the script that grabbed your
attention and really grabbed your
attention I mean I'm just curious to
have just about life rights how does
that work for some because they're
public figures obviously what I mean
well it's interesting they talked about
that date in 2007 prior to the election
rich read an article in The New York
Times where they talked about the first
date and everything on that date
actually happened except the community
summit kind of thing that he did he did
that three or four dates later he waited
for her do that that's where he actually
got her a thing but uh all that you know
if we're going to Baskin Robbins see and
do the right thing go into a bar they
went to the Art Institute
so all those events they've talked about
very openly in the past well and Twinkie
I want to ask about your involvement you
were just talking earlier about how when
you first heard about the script and how
you got involved in it was yes share
that as well absolutely I have cast tika
on numerous occasions as a casting
director cast her in a couple of
projects including Sparkle and we became
fast friends and she attended one of my
events where I speak to young actors and
artists and I share with them to create
I'm like your hashtag should be hashtag
create like that's your job and and
leveraging your celebrity in order to
create and she called me one day and she
said remember when you said about
leveraging my celebrity I have something
that's perfect and it's an independent
and I I just it's got to be done twinky
it has to be done so she emailed it to
me and I read it and we sat down at
dinner and I said I'm in what do you
need me to do like who do I need to put
it in front of what do you need me to do
so that's that's how it started for me
three years ago and then how did you
find the the actor played the role of
Barack Obama I'm kind of curious very
specifically like were you looking for a
look or mannerisms or what you know like
where artists so there are times when
you can do a spot-on kind of thing and
there are times when it's someone that
has the feel you know what I mean and
and and be open so I try to be open
about it I've had numerous conversations
especially with my brother Jeff about
Denzel playing Malcolm X and he was like
open open up sis open so you know I I
had to open and as I grow as an artist I
realized I'm looking for the feel that's
what I'm looking for the feel if you
when you feel it there's nothing wrong
if everything is right with the feeling
and the cherry on top is the look and so
when I when he sent in his audition tape
and I sent it over to Richard Richard
was like absolutely not he's trying to
do Barack Obama and I was like okay
breathe all right
because you know it's the feeling so I
what about you
what about him bothers you like what is
it Richard well he's just trying to do
it and it's just I was like alright
breathe it's gonna be okay this is what
we're gonna do you try it and you tell
me what you think this is my feeling but
tell me what you think
turning off the sound and he did it and
then he understood exactly what I was
saying and I said now give him all the
notes you want and let's try it take two
and that's how it happened and do they
perform together and another audition
cuz they it was a chemistry and it was I
had tears it was as soon as I had tears
and turned around all these guys they
were like yep we're done Twiggy's crying
it was easy once you saw them like you
were done yeah I was and even I want to
ask about you know you you work for the
other filmmakers like Charles Burnett
and I was won't want to know about what
is maybe just your you talk briefly
about your process in terms of scoring a
film how do you approach it in jet well
the main thing is to try to tune into
the filmmakers muse it's not so much
getting direction or sculling it out as
it is what inspired the director to do
it this way to direct the editor what
are the rhythm of the cuts what's the
general feeling that and I always
cross-examine my directors first
question is what do you want people to
feel from this scene what is it you want
people to feel when they leave the
theater that's what I really work from
because those are real emotional values
and I can translate that into music or
style or instrumentation those things
are I think of lesser importance than
addressing what it is that the writer
director wants to people to feel well
it's such a unique story to that that
it's it's a one-day story and I felt the
music does a really great job of making
that journey from you know beginning
afternoon to evening and it was when I
said something you were thinking about
in the film was that one of the
directors yeah yeah it was really
important to keep it really simple and
just gonna have one theme one sort of
sound that would they would tie all the
different scenes together and kinda just
frame the emotion that was already
it was already inherent in the
performances but in this particular case
I had two instruments made custom-made
for this one for Barack and one for
Michelle
Barack's instrument is something called
a baritone guitar but it has 31 frets
instead of 12 which means you can get
these really fine gradations of pitch
that I think addressed the nuance of
some of their performances and then for
Michelle I have an instrument that a
violin maker friend of mine made we call
it the transcendental and it's a cross
between a pedal steel guitar and a cello
and a Vietnamese instrument called the
Dan bow so you blow it like a cello but
the pedals can change the pitch and you
can pluck it you can also hit it with
mallets but I use it mostly as a kind of
cello substitute something you couldn't
quite identify but it was familiar and
and in her case the first thing you hear
it's just one note because she's not
given anything right and as the movie
goes along then that
that instrument starts to open up and at
the very end they play the same melody
together with the guitar and I want to I
wanted to ask you to you've you have a
very extensive filmography and you've
worked on a lot of action films like
Hellboy 2 and and Mission Possible Ghost
Protocol and I'm wondering how did you
approach this project was it differently
from an action film or is theirs onra
that you like working with more than the
other I'll take any any genre definitely
but this was the movie that I cut right
before this was a sama Hayek kind of
genre or movie and one thing that was
really refreshing about coming to this
movie is that nobody died
appreciated that you know but there's
different challenges I mean I'm cutting
an action movie right now and it's been
enlightening to kind of to see the
different challenges of eating between
cutting and all dialogue film and going
into more action the cutting something
that's entirely dialogue it's even given
the limited amount of footage that we
would have had on a film of this size
it's challenging because you have to
really figure out I mean not only what
we want the actors to say what do we
want the story to be but the cut points
are also not you know they're not as
obvious as if you've got like a fight
scene yeah that's probably my daughter
in the back and so it it was a good
challenge you know for me and for rich
to kind of discover together how do we
pace this the way that we want it to be
paced and how do we communicate the
story that we want to be told I really
like the ending with that last cut
between the two of them and I'm
wondering if that was something in the
scripture that came out of the editing
room where it's a little bit of a mix
the the original script had Michelle's
mother come back at the end and be like
so do you know not a date and it took a
while to get that kind of that back and
forth right and how much time do we
spend on both characters and I really
liked you know we had one version where
it was you just saw Michelle once you
just saw Barack once I like coming back
to Michelle for that second little just
even it's just a you know a tiny little
peek you know she does that little thing
with her lip and looks away and it's
like it for me that was the perfect way
to end the film that's great go to their
credit to I got to say that Evan and
rich liked the cut that I saw first
that's pretty much the cut you see like
there wasn't right there wasn't a lot of
changes or notes and every single scene
we shot is in the film so there wasn't
like anything you know it's all there
and to their credit it was like right on
point right when they showed it to us
and you premiered the film on Sunday and
so I was wearing for all you what was
the experience going there how coming
out of it out of the festival how was
all of that for for any of you I loved
it it was awesome
yeah a great community at Sundance it's
just absolutely beautiful and was
brilliant and it's got a standing
ovation and you know a lot of the cast
was there and and it was an awesome
awesome time and epic event they were
feeling the love
do you know if Brock and Michelle Obama
I've seen the film they have the film
they don't know I've seen the film but I
know a lot of people in their circle
have seen the film I don't I feel like
it's not very presidential for him to
come out and say they have to come see
the speech where she would I wish she
would but I understand why it's
especially this week yeah well I want to
thank you all for for being here and
thank you for bringing the thank you
[Applause]